Senator Cinema do you feel like America
is aware that one year ago from right
now uh Congress passed the single
biggest piece of gun legislation in
nearly three decades I think most
Americans probably don't know it because
the law was so substantive and so
historic it's going to take years for us
to roll out not just all the policy
implications but all the programming the
funding the resources that will help
change the face of Mental Health
Services in our country and school
safety so there's a lot of work left to
be done not just to educate Americans
about it but to help them actually see
and feel the impact of these changes
when President Joe Biden signed the bill
into law he said this will save lives
one year on is that true Senator Murphy
I think there's no doubt that this bill
is Saving Lives we already have data
telling us that we have prevented young
people in crisis from getting guns that
shouldn't be able to under the law we've
already started to spend money for
Community anti gun violence programs for
school-based mental health programs
there's some encouraging news so far
this year if you look at the first five
months of 2023 gun violence rates are
down in some of America's biggest cities
criminologists think that part of what's
happening is the beginning impacts of
this law and so I think just the data is
beginning to tell us that this law is
starting to have a real impact because
it's big and there's a lot in it I think
I should ask each of you and I'll start
with you Senator to tell us what is it
that you're proudest of in this
legislation I'm proud of the fact that
we were able to pass the biggest
investment in mental health in history
and that we fulfilled a promise that was
made 50 years ago if you remember back
in the late 60s early 70s we more or
less shut down some of the facilities
that we were warehousing people with
chronic behavioral health problems and
we did that but we also promised that we
were going to make Behavior rural Health
more accessible more integrated with our
health system didn't do it for 50 years
the way I think that the way we were
able to get into a room and within an
hour judge that we could get to a good
outcome is we all agreed that behavioral
health had to be the foundation of
everything we did and Kirsten's right is
going to take 10 years for every state
to become eligible but it's founded on a
bipartisan effort that was passed in I
think 2017 and the states that were in
the program and the pilot done an
extraordinary job so we need to to
educate we need to let people know this
isn't a gun bill this is a gun safety
there are gun safety Provisions in it
but this is the most significant
investment Congress has ever made and a
framework that we know works that's
going to benefit people struggling with
mental health I've heard you say quite
entertainingly that bipartisanship is
not about Kumbaya it's not about we're
all friends it's done on a transactional
basis so in this transaction I just
heard what you got what you're proud of
what were you willing to take from these
two and from the left side of the aisle
in terms of gun safety what made you
comfortable with what they
well I you know in our first meeting
with uh uh with the three of us and uh
senator cornyn from Texas uh what made
that meeting so impactful is what we
agreed was not going to be on the table
and the things that are just we have
very different very different priorities
very different points of view on certain
aspects of uh gun legislation I'm a
strong supporter of the Second Amendment
and uh I want to make sure that all
law-abiding citizens have an opportunity
to buy a gun and anybody who's at risk
or has a criminal record doesn't so we
we have those foundational discussions
early and that told me this was a
transaction that was worth investing in
and I knew that I was going to get some
political blowback for it but I think it
aged well just to add to what Chris said
since this bill was implemented over 107
000 people under the age of 21 have
applied to purchase a gun
99.8 percent of them have been approved
uh bisca is responsible for fewer than I
think 400 or right at 400 denials and if
you look at the reason for it thank
goodness that we at least save that
person's life who was going to buy a gun
and maybe somebody else's yeah there you
go you focus on the the are the
approvals meaning the the right is
upheld and I know in your answer you
bring up the cases where there was a
denial for good cause and I do too and I
and I agree with Chris that if you take
a look at the specific cases cases in
North Carolina there's no reasonable
person that would look at the
information that the FBI looked at and
would draw a different conclusion about
whether or not they should walk out of a
store with a gun so this wouldn't be
your critic saying this is Senator
Tillis giving the American government
more reasons to take more guns away from
more people right and that's not what
the Bill's about at all I'm from Arizona
and we are strong Second Amendment
supporters but what this bill really
does is transform the way that we think
about violence in our community you know
I'm a social worker and my first job was
as a school social worker actually
before that when I was in college I
worked at a domestic violence shelter so
when you asked about what are the two
most important things in this law I'm
going to tell you what the two things
are that matter the most to me one a
historic 15 billion dollar investment in
Mental Health Services not just in
schools not just in communities but for
everyone in our country who is suffering
and isn't getting the help that they
need we know that individuals who take
up firearms and engage in Mass violence
every single one of them is mentally
challenged and Disturbed every single
one of them and we're preventing some of
those acts of violence by getting folks
that help and that's why it'll take
years and years for this to really play
out so that to me is one of the most
important things about this legislation
is that we're addressing the root cause
of this violence the second thing that
I'm really proud of is that we close the
boyfriend loophole now a lot of people
may not even know what this is but until
just last year
an individual could threaten or hurt
their partner that they didn't live with
and still get access to a weapon and
that often led to assault and sometimes
murder and for years domestic violence
Advocates had tried to address this
problem while still protecting second
amendment rights
we together with Senator cornyn we close
that Circle we've actually protected all
of those survivors of domestic violence
in this country
that's incredibly important and as
you've noticed the two things I just
mentioned
actually aren't about guns or gun
violence they're about what happens when
people who shouldn't have access to
those weapons get them which is why you
say this will take years and years
before we see the full effect that's
right because you're going to the causes
underneath of it that's right the root
causes and some of the people who will
benefit from treatment or from being
recognized as Unworthy of the right they
they have yet to come to the point where
they have contact with the system or
they're getting help when they need it
that's right so one of the things that's
really important about this legislation
is the idea that we're doing additional
checks for these young men between the
ages of 18 and 21 young adults we know
statistically that these are the folks
who are most likely to get access to a
weapon and hurt others and themselves so
adding in this additional check not only
does it help us ensure that those folks
aren't getting access to a weapon to
hurt others we're also ensuring they
don't get access to women to hurt
themselves and instead we're getting
them access to the treatment that we
know that folks throughout this country
need yeah and that's what's going to
take years and years for us to see the
sea change in our country yeah right
suicide is the leading cause of gun
deaths uh followed by murder uh mass
shootings are a huge public issues
tragedies that drive fear and make
school and church in the grocery store a
different kind of place but there are a
small percentage overall I know you
wanted to do more to attack the mass
shooting problem I know this is not your
end point what made you feel good about
signing on to this on a journey to where
you want to go legislatively
I think the American public wants to see
us working together on a problem that's
existential right I mean nothing matters
more to families in this country than
the safety of their kids right you'd
give anything your life savings right
your home your car in order to protect
your children
I think people in this country really
want to see us putting aside our
differences and working together to
protect people from gun violence and so
that means both sides stepping outside
of their comfort zones that means for me
somebody that supports Banning assault
weapons being willing to sit down and do
something that's incremental but
important on the issue of mass shootings
in that first meeting you know we looked
at the data everything we did here was
Data informed and what we saw is that
these Mass Shooters tend to be younger
they often are 18 19 20 years old and so
what we could find agreement on was that
we should just at the very least be more
careful about how we sell weapons long
guns to that specific population
and even though that's not as far as I'd
like to go that's a really important
step forward that's saving lives as we
speak and the whole exercise to me was
worthwhile because it's proving to the
American people that democracy is not so
broken that we can't find a way to come
together even on a topic that for 30
years has been a real political hot spot
on the other hand the American people
did have to wait 30 years countless mass
shootings major American tragedies I'm
curious from all three of you I'd like
to know is this the end of a
conversation or does this feel like the
beginning of something more well the
good news is that the four of us who
work together in this legislation in
addition to having strong commitment and
dedication to solving this Challenge and
making a difference in the lives of
American people we're also friends
we talked together all the time and
we're working together on New Endeavors
new issues that Americans face every day
so I think as Chris was saying Not only
was it important that we hit this huge
milestone to transform the way we
address mental health in this country to
ensure that young adults aren't getting
access to weapons to hurt themselves or
others when they're not when they're not
mentally healthy to have it we're also
demonstrating to the American people and
to our colleagues that we can do hard
things that it's okay to have a
difference of opinion and still work
together and solve a problem and we're
continuing to do it on other pieces of
legislation together so the answer I
would say to your question is absolutely
resoundingly yes there's of course more
that we can do together and we're
demonstrating that every single day I
see you nodding Senator Tillis one area
that is not covered in this bill but has
broad support with gun owners with
Republicans is universal background
checks is that something you can see
voting yes on in the future uh nothing
no one thing gets voted on in isolation
and so anybody who would give an answer
that question I think is being naive
about the political process here look we
talked about a lot of things before we
determine what was going to be in the
but then the Contours of something we'd
negotiate I'll look at anything in the
future in the context of
what the what the legislation does more
broadly uh we had discussions about
stuff that we both knew we weren't going
to talk about so you'll go through that
same sort of triaging to get down to a
specific legislation that you want to
drive I do want to go back on the the
Investments though because we are
talking about Behavioral Health but you
should take a look at the things that
we're trying to do to help with school
hardening the things that we're trying
to do to help with school counselors to
identify kids who may be at risk and and
uh and address violence issues other
things that are a problem the hardening
is interesting Senator cornyn who's not
here with us I know he spent some time
touring a school that used the money
from this bill to harden its Security in
various ways so that is a key component
of it
um you know I was a school social worker
in a community in Phoenix called
Sunnyslope and we didn't have any kind
of physical security anyone could just
walk on campus at any time and during my
time as a school social worker these
guys know this we talked about it when
we were negotiating
there was gun violence there were
students at my school who died at the
hands of guns so I understand how
important it is to both address the
issue of hardening a school and
investing in the Mental Health
Counselors and social workers on those
campuses and ensuring there's community
services for when the kids get to
Community College it has to be this
whole wrap-around approach so that as
Chris was saying parents can go to bed
at night knowing their kids are safe
yeah it's not one or the other and what
I think is important about our
legislation and the partnership that we
formed while working together is we
didn't approach it as one or the other
or even as I'll give you this to get
this it was about understanding the
whole concept together of how to create
more Safety and Security and peace of
mind for those families I mean one
obstacle to more cooperation on the gun
issue between the three of you and
Senator cornyn is
there is a wing of your party in
particular that doesn't want any
restriction no matter how carefully
drawn and in fact I have to bring up
that you were I believe censured I was
for a different matter was it that
nothing to do with guns well there were
some people blatant violation of the
party platform at the end of the day
facts don't lie there were a lot of
people in my there were some elements I
won't even say a lot because there were
a number of people who supported what I
did but
the uh the reality is much of their
concern was rooted in data right and now
we have data 99.8 percent some of the
people who opposed the bill said it was
going to be that it was going to be
impossible for someone under the age of
21 uh to get an approval yeah 107 600
have been approved yeah uh fewer than
three or four hundred have been uh
disapproved under the added standard
that we have for uh viscous so that's
false
um uh though it was said that we had
passed a red flag law we didn't as a
matter of fact we passed and this was
something important to my office
legislation that says states can apply
for support to implement their red flag
laws but you've got to be in compliance
with due process guess what most of the
States including red states that have
red flag laws can't qualify because they
don't have the basic due process
constraints that uh that my friends here
supported in the bill so while President
Biden May tout it you're saying in
actuality
the states are not pursuing red flag
laws he's actually wrong in terms of
this and the people on my side of the
aisle who said that this was going to
create a flood of red flag laws we
didn't set a federal red flag law and we
did say that if you pass them then the
rights of the person whose second
amendment rights are going to be
Abridged has to have their day in court
you have to limit the number of people
that can raise the flag so this was this
was probably one of the last things we
ended up getting done it's a tricky
business yeah well it isn't Tom was a
very tough negotiator his position was
not every state is ready to implement a
red flag law so one you have to make
that money eligible for other types of
Court interventions if a state doesn't
want to use it mental health courts
veterans courts that's what we do in
Arizona but you also have to have due
process rights that's right and so part
of what delayed the bill was making sure
that we had language in there that Tom
and other conservatives could support an
attorney that made clear that if a state
was going to move forward with a red
flag law even a democratic State like
mine they had to have due process rights
in place for anybody who is having their
weapons temporarily taken away and those
due process rights that now apply to
every blue state in a in in addition to
every red state are in there because you
know people like Tom were driving a hard
bargain so back but a good bargain yeah
okay
all I asked but I've said repeatedly I
believe this bill ends age as well I
think it ages well when every state
become a part of the reason it's 10
years is because it'll take that long to
get the funding to every state that
applies for it so it just takes time to
implement as it did yeah and the the
states that implemented the Baseline uh
seven or eight years ago but the numbers
don't lie 99.8 percent of everybody
under the age of 21 since this bill was
passed in a Democrat Administration
have been granted the right to purchase
a weapon and a few hundred we've said
you may want to you may want to take a
pass here and I hear from gun dealers
all the time saying look we have people
come in and we can see they're in
distress that's right and they and and
thanks to the gun dealers and say buddy
this is just not your day yeah because
they can turn them away so that so then
if you look at the red flag laws one of
the things I'd ask my friends in red
states to do is look at your red State
red flag laws and get them in compliance
with due process because none of them
are at the standard that we set with the
bipartisan safer communities act just
two more questions because I'm mindful
of time and one of them is about
something you said earlier you brought
up the idea of an assault weapon ban
I don't even think you guys can agree on
the definition of assault weapon let
alone a ban
Hey listen what made this bill possible
is that we knew what we couldn't agree
on and on that first day when we sat in
did you talk about the definition of
assault weapon this is the term we
didn't because we knew that that wasn't
going to be it would have been a really
short meeting yeah but we did this
entire piece of legislation from first
meeting to passing the senate in 28 days
wow we didn't have time to debate about
stuff that doesn't matter exactly and
what I mean by that is simple simply
this
when you're putting together a
bipartisan coalition to try and get
something done that's going to make a
meaningful difference in Americans lives
you don't waste any time on the stuff
that doesn't matter you focus 100 on
what you can get done and what I'll tell
you is that the four of us that's what
we did all day long every day we spent
zero time debating the esoteric matters
of the items on which there was an
agreement yeah we wouldn't have gotten
this done had we had done the typical
thing that partisans do right the I want
this and you want that we spent our time
on what we could get done and and again
really focused on
what can we do to save lives help
families feel peace of mind at night and
address the Mental Health crisis in our
country
so we didn't spend time on that other
stuff
on the on the subject of time
and because we're running out of it
right here in this interview
um the history of gun legislation in
this country is such that tragedy drives
the politics in the 1930s it was
gangsters and Street violence and
machine guns in the 1960s it was public
assassinations and riots and crime and
now we're dealing with mass shootings
and I think people watching at home will
ask themselves
how many do we have to suffer through
before it's over it's done or is is the
reality of the message just that
the price of the Second Amendment the
price of Freedom as it is defined by
many in this country is that there's
always going to be gun violence in
America
well there's always going to be violence
in America and I for one think there's
always going to be a second amendment
protection in the Constitution for good
reasons so why don't we figure out what
we can do early to avert whatever Choice
someone uses to kill themselves to kill
someone else to create a mass a weapon
of mass destruction that's the reality
of society what we need to do is start
early and that's what this bill did to
lessen the chances that the numbers of
people who could be at risk and make a
decision to harm themselves or somebody
else regardless of what they use to do
it America's always been a more violent
place I think we're going to continue to
have gun violence but we don't have to
accept the levels that we have today I
understand that this country focuses on
the mass shootings they are cataclysmic
it's hard to understand why those things
happen but the suicides and the domestic
violence murders they matter just as
much and the good news is this year we
we are seeing a decline not in mass
shootings but in those other homicides
those other types of violence crimes and
I think our bill has something to do
with that and I hope well this country
will remain fascinated for the right
reasons on the mass shootings I hope
people pay attention if that Trend
continues that the homicides the
suicides and The Accidental shootings
keep going down if that happens if that
continues to happen I think it's this
bipartisan bill that had a lot to do
with it Senator Cinema you're credited
with getting all this started that's the
way the story is told you ran here you
ran there you put people in a room and
got this started that's right can you
get something else started again
we get something started every day here
the whole reason I come to work every
day is to find Opportunities to make
bipartisan achievements that make a
difference in Americans lives I couldn't
be more proud of the work that the four
of us did you know you mentioned that I
got it started that day and it's true
but I heard Chris's speech on the floor
after the Uvalde shooting and it touched
me and I saw my friend John cornyn fly
home to Texas
to visit Uvalde and it was those two
instances
that led me to say that's it we have to
do something
and then of course I texted this guy and
this guy texted me and then I texted
John and said that's it let's do it so
we the next day the very next day
met in our first meeting and after that
meeting all four of us said yeah we're
going to get this done
so can we do more absolutely can we do
this type of collaboration absolutely
I think what I'd like the American
public to know is this
the difference that we make in the lives
of the people that we serve happens
incrementally bit by bit
and so the pressure that exists whether
it's Accenture or someone protesting
outside an office to say my way or the
highway or All or Nothing
is a real disservice
because it's this kind of work where you
sit down and
find what you can do together and push
the ball along to save lives and help
families feel safer that is the work
that the people deserve from their
government that is what we should do so
can we do it again absolutely
it's amazing that you you know most
Americans can't plan dinner over a text
message chain and you guys planned out
major legislation
so well done on that text thread by the
end of that month it was
so was the call log oh yeah I we talked
to each other more than we talk to
anyone else in our lives during that
time